Welcome everybody
to the next lecture of functional
programming 101x.
Today we're going to talk about list
comprehensions.
List comprehensions are
a mechanism to write code that
manipulates collections.
If we look at most programming
languages,
most of the features in a programming
language
have to do with dealing with collections.
If you look at
a traditional imperative language
such as Java or C#,
it has a wide range of mechanisms to
deal with collections.
For loops, while loops, do while loops
foreach loops, continue, break
and all these constructs are there to
iterate over collections.
Now of course mathematicians have been
dealing with collections
for centuries.
For mathematicians the favorite
collection type is set.
Sets however are computationally a
little bit awkward.
Because when you have a set it
means that duplicated
elements are removed. Which implies that
you need equality to deal with sets.
Especially in a functional language like
Haskell
it's very hard, well impossible,
you have to solve the halting problem
to decide equality between functions.
So what
Haskell did, it took some of the ideas
that mathematicians have
used
for a long time to deal with sets and
simplified them to work over lists.
Lists are
my favorite collection type and the
reason is that a list
just gives you the bare minimum to
deal with a collection.
You can, as you have seen, if we have a
list that's composed out of a head and a
tail
you can decompose that list recursively
by just picking off the first element
one by one.
And that's very convenient and
that puts
very few restrictions on the collection
type.
Unless sets where you assume
equality of the elements or arrays where
you assume
constant time indexing. Sets
are in some sense the most pure form
of collection types. In Java eight,
they call these lists streams.
To emphasize that these are
collections where you can only
access the elements
one by one. In that sense
Haskell lists are an example of Java
eight streams in that philosophy.
Alright let's
look at how mathematicians use
so-called set comprehensions to define
sets.
Here's an example of a set.
It's a set of all squares
with values
between one and five. It's x
squared
where x is taken from the set
from one to five.
The result of this is the set
.
But as I said, if we take
x to range over functions then this
becomes really hard to implement.
So what people did
in functional languages is take the same
notation the same ideas
but instead of sets, use lists.
Set comprehensions from mathematics
become list comprehensions in Haskell.
Here's the same example written as a
list comprehension. Here you see
it's the list of square numbers
x squared where x is taken from
the list
one to five. You read this as x
is taken from the list one to five.
If you evaluate this you will see that
this returns the list [1,4,9,16,25].
But as a list not a set.
The expression
x taken from one to five, that's called a
generator
and the reason it's called a
generator is because it
defines how to generate values
for x. So x is taken from that set.
Of course since everything
in Haskell, and that's a good
aspect of programming languages, has to be
compositional so you should be able to
just recursively use the same
structures over and over again.
Comprehensions can have multiple
generators.
Here you see an example of that:
we take all pairs (x, y)
Where x is drawn from one, two, three,
and y
is drawn from four, five. What you see
is that the y varies
faster then the x. The result list is
(1,4) (1,5)
(2,4) (2,5) (3,4) (3,5).
Another way to look at these nested
generators or multiple generators is
like
a nested loop where y is inner loop
and the x is the outer loop.
If we swap the order of the
generator
then now x
varies most quickly because this becomes
the inner loop. What we get now
is, but notice that we still
have here (x,y). We only swap
the order
of the generators not the order of the
variables.
Now instead of
this guy moving fastest, you get
x moving fastest. The result is (1,4)
(2,4) (3,4) et cetera
This notion of generators
you will recognize that
in many many programming languages.
In Haskell these are list comprehensions
if you use python
it also has list comprehensions.
Scala has for comprehensions. F#
has comprehensions.
C# and Visual Basic
have LINQ comprehensions.
If you look at the language like
SQL
which is completely built on top of
comprehensions.
Only there you don't write them this concisely.
You write select from where
et cetera. But it's basically the same
idea so by studying
list comprehensions in Haskell you
will be well equipped
to use the same ideas in whatever
language you encounter them in.
Alright,
now
we have seen a few simple examples
with generators
where the generators only had constants.
But generators can also depend on each
other.
Just like when you have a loop,
the inner loop
can use variables from the outer loop.
With comprehensions
that's no different. If we look here
we say x is drawn from one to three.
And then
y is drawn from x to three.
So x is in scope in the generators that
come after it. If we execute this
comprehension
we get the list (1,1)
because y is drawn from one to three.
Because x starts out at one, so we
get (1,1) (1,2) (1,3).
Then y is exhausted.
We're going to check the next value
of x, that will be two.
Now y is taken from two to three so
we say
two to three and then the last iteration
we take x to be three and then y is
drawn from the list
three to three, so that is the last value is just
(3,3). But again you’re
totally familiar with this because this
is the same as how nested loops work
in any language. The inner loop
can
use variables defined in outer loops.
One of the nice things
of comprehensions and especially of
dependent generators
is that you can write very concise code.
For example, if we want to take a list
of lists
and flatten them into a single list
we can do that with the following
comprehension.
We say: just give me every list
out of that list of lists.
Then just give me every element of
that list
and return that. This is a doubly
nested loop that goes over
every list in this list of lists
and just
yields all the values to return
a single list of type a, of the same
element type
as the original list. When we
concatenate [1,2,3] [4,5] and [6]
the result will be [1,2,3,4,5,6].
Very very
concise code that we can write
using comprehensions. Now the next thing
besides generators that you want to use
in a comprehension, and that's also
used a lot in set comprehensions is to
allow filters.
You want to
have x drawn from some collection
but you want to throw out certain values
for which a predicate does not hold.
For example, if we want to have
all the even numbers between one and ten
we can just say x is drawn from
one to ten
and filter out only the even numbers.
The result
of this is a list [2,4,6,8,10].
The even numbers between one and ten.
In SQL you will recognize
this as a SELECT WHERE.
The WHERE clause here is called a
guard
in Haskell and if you use a LINQ
list comprehension or
comprehension syntax that will be also
be called
WHERE.
Here's an
example that uses guards to take
a number and break it down into its
factors.
What are the factors? Well we take a
number n,
we take all the numbers between 1 and
n.
And then we only
retain those for which n modulo x is zero.
The factors of 15; we start out
with all the numbers between
1 and 15 and then we throw out all the
numbers
for which n modulo x is not zero.
In this case the factors are [1,3,5,15].
Then we can use this
factors function
to define a very simple
predicate to check whether a number
is prime.
A number is prime if the factors of that
number are exactly the list [1,n].
For example, fifteen is not a prime
because the factors are not just one and
fifteen.
It's one three five and fifteen. But seven
is a prime because you can check by
using GHCi, or your
own favorite programming language, that
the factors of seven are one and seven.
So we decide that
seven is a prime.
If we want to check
what are the primes up to a
certain number.
Well we can write this simple list
comprehension where we say:
give me all the numbers between two and
n where n is the parameter to
this
function. Then I only want to
maintain the prime numbers. I filter out
all the numbers that are not prime.
If I want to have
all the prime numbers up to 40
I just run this list comprehension
and I get all the prime numbers.
Of course this is not the most efficient
way
to compute prime numbers but I think
it's a very nice illustration
of using list comprehensions. See you
in the next chapter.